2024 Republican presidential candidate
Chris Christie did a CNN Town Hall last
night and he again proved he is really
the only serious Republican presidential
candidate I tell you this with no fear
or hesitation because it appears as
though Chris Christie has absolutely no
chance of winning that nomination he's
making too much sense he's willing to
criticize Donald Trump he answers
questions when they are asked of him I
will be the first to say Chris Christie
from 2016 to 2020 seemed to support most
of what Trump did and for that I think
he is horrible but if you compare him
and contrast him with the other
presidential candidates including Donald
Trump and Rhonda Sanctus and others the
Sanctus DeSantis and now I'm doing it a
running for the 2024 Republican
nomination this is the only serious
person and he actually could do a good
job in debating Joe Biden because he is
intelligent he's willing to answer
questions he's direct check out this
clip from last night's Town Hall Chris
Christie saying they're blaming
everybody but Trump for this indictment
what about blaming Trump for the things
he did and we're in a situation where
there are people in my own party who are
blaming doj
how about blame him right he did it he
kept he took documents he wasn't
supposed to take he kept it when they
asked him back for them they got a grand
jury subpoena he refused to comply they
raided his home finally because he
refused to comply that all those things
were brought on himself as was this
indicted this is accurate what about
blaming the person who did the thing and
if you look in the comments to these
clips you see all these Maga people
saying Chris Christie is a rhino he's
not serious no one's taking him
seriously it is true that because Maga
has taken over the Republican Party the
one guy who actually makes some sense
and is more in line with the Mitt Romney
John McCain type Republicans seems to
have no shot now Steve Schmidt said last
week in our interview that he actually
thinks Chris Christie does have a shot
we will see here is Chris Christie
weighing in on the indictment itself I
want to ask you about the indictments
that we've seen yesterday former
Attorney General Bill Barr called the
indictment quote very damning and he
said if even half of it is true then
he's toast your former U.S attorney is
he right
it is a very tight very detailed
evidence-laden uh indictment and the
conduct in there is is awful
I mean put aside taking the documents in
the first place but then when you start
getting asked Anderson in May of 21
nicely with a letter from the archivist
saying could you please give it back
and you ignore it ignore it ignore it
then they come with a grand jury
subpoena and then according to the
indictment you tell your lawyers tell
them we don't have anything even though
you have dozens and dozens of boxes of
material
um that's obstruction of justice if it's
true and so I think the former Attorney
General is absolutely right this is an
actual proper legal analysis from a
prosecutor who is not so blinded by
partisanship and he also has an
incentive to criticize Trump obviously
Chris Christie again making the point at
another moment we blame everybody but
ourselves for our losses we should blame
the fact that Trump is a loser and he
lost everything for us an argument I've
been making for a while now it makes me
feel even more important
I'm just telling you
I've known him for 22 years
the only thing he understands the is
force
the only thing he understands is coming
right at him and making your case
and if these other candidates don't want
to do it the American people and
Republican primary voters have to start
to understand this
when did it when did we get to the point
we're always playing our adversaries for
the weakness of our candidates right oh
it's the Democrats fault it's doj's
fault it's this person's fault it's the
media's fault how bad is his
he hasn't won a damn thing since 2016.
three-time loser
2018 we lost the house 2020 we lost the
White House we lost the United States
Senate a couple of weeks later in 2021
and in 2022 we lost two more
governorships another senate seat and
barely took the House of Representatives
when Joe Biden had the most incompetent
first two years I've ever seen in my
life that I disagree with but it's
obviously what he has to say
loser loser loser
now we're getting going
it'll be different this time why
why will it be different this time those
arguments need to be made
and I'm not afraid to make them this is
the only guy who's actually saying this
stuff why why won't Tim Scott do this
why won't DeSantis do this why would
they are all weak other than Chris
Christie he's polling 1.3 percent we'll
see where it goes
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below